as the country debates how schools
should teach the role of
slavery in our nation's history author
clint smith
is taking a critical eye to how it's
being portrayed
at some important historical sites his
new book is
how the word is passed a reckoning with
the history of slavery
across america smith describes his
visits to places including virginia's
monticello louisiana's angola prison
and new york city he examines how they
confront
or failed to confront their pasts smith
shared an excerpt from the book during a
recent visit to washington dc's
african-american civil war museum and
memorial
part of what i love about this monument
and this memorial is that
it pays tribute to a collective group of
people sometimes
in the early stages of the book i would
come down here and just think about
all of the people who fought this war to
make sure that my ancestors wouldn't
remain
enslaved and that i am part of a long
lineage and tradition
of people who fought for freedom and
fought for liberation
and fought for opportunities that they
knew they might not necessarily see
themselves
[Music]
the history of slavery is the history of
the united states
it was not peripheral to our founding it
was central to it
it is not irrelevant to our contemporary
society
it created it the history is in our soil
it is in our policies and it must too be
in our memories
in order for our country to collectively
move forward
it is not enough to have a patchwork of
places that are honest about this
history
while being surrounded by other spaces
that undermine it
it must be a collective endeavor to
learn and confront the story of slavery
and how it shaped the world we live in
today we can learn this history from the
scholars
who have unearthed generations of
evidence of all that slavery was
from the voices of the enslaved in the
stories and narratives they left behind
by standing on the land where it
happened
by remembering that land by marking that
land
by not allowing what happened there to
be forgotten
and by listening to our own families by
sitting down and having conversations
with our elders
and getting insight into all that
they've seen at some point
it is no longer a question of whether we
can learn this history
but whether or not we have the
collective will
to reckon with it
and clint smith joins us now good
morning clint thank you so much for
being with us
thank you so much for having me let me
start with a question you asked at the
at the end there
do you think this nation does have the
collective will to reckon with this
history
i think we're moving towards it i think
we certainly have a long way to go
i think if we consider where we were
several years ago
i think that our country has a much more
sophisticated understanding
at least many people do of how racism
and the history of racism is not just an
interpersonal phenomenon
but a historic one and a systemic one
and one that is embedded into all of our
social economic and political
infrastructure
and i think that we are developing a
better understanding a better framework
and a better language
with which to make sense of why the
contemporary landscape of inequality
looks the way that it does today
and how the reason one community looks
one way and another community looks
another way
is not because of people in those
communities but is because of what has
been done to those communities
generation after generation after
generation yeah this is a really
fascinating read
because because the history is taught
somewhat differently in the sites that
you go to
more honestly in some places than others
one place you go to is new york city
uh which which i only learned much later
in my life
was where the economy of slavery was
central to the economy of new york city
but you also you point out largely how
important it was to the u.s economy this
blew me away by 1860
the nearly 4 million enslaved people
were by far the country's most valuable
economic asset
valued at about three and a half billion
dollars they were worth more than all
the countries
manufacturing and railroads combined
i had no idea i'll be honest
yeah i think a lot of people know in the
abstract that
uh slavery was central to the economic
infrastructure of the country in the
18th and 19th century but historians
like david blight who i cite there
really emphasized that again in 1860 the
4 million enslaved black people
were worth more than every bank factory
and railroad combined with more than all
of the manufacturing in this country
and i think it's important to recognize
how the labor and
forced exploitation of millions of
enslaved people
is quite literally part of the reason
why the united states exists as a global
economic superpower today
clint i want to second what anthony said
about i had no idea
i had spent some time in monticello with
uh ta-nehisi coates who was doing
research for his book the water dancer
and one of the tour guides told me that
when people come to visit
white visitors in particular they either
get very angry because they said we
didn't come here to hear this
about thomas jefferson's history why are
you telling us this
they're either mad or they're either
shocked and you you talk about a
conversation with two women donna and
grace
could you talk about that because i
think that's pretty typical of how
people feel
yeah so i went to monticello and
monticello has several tours that one
can take and one of them
is focused specifically on the history
of slavery at monticello and focusing on
jefferson's relationship to slavery
and also the experience of the enslaved
people who lived at monticello and so i
was on this tour
led by a guy named david thorson and
these two women
donna and grace were on the tour as well
and i was watching them during the tour
as we as david was discussing
jefferson's relationship to slavery
and their mouths were gate they were
clearly unnerved and i went up to them
after
and asked them what they thought and
they were like i had no idea that
jefferson owned slaves
yeah i had no idea that monticello was a
plantation and mind you these are people
who bought plane tickets
who got hotel rooms who rented cars who
came to this home as a sort of
pilgrimage almost to see the third
president of the united states in his
home
and had no conception of this place
being a plantation or that this person
wasn't in slavery and i think it's a
microcosm for how so many people across
this country
don't understand the history of slavery
in any sort of meaningful way and in any
way that is commensurate
with the impact that it actually has had
on this country yeah and as you point
out clinton the book in many ways they
haven't really put a face on it they
don't really understand
you know that there were children
involved and how they were involved it's
a fascinating read the book is how the
word is passed
it's on sale now clint smith thank you
so much for being with us this morning
yeah he says just because something is
difficult to accept doesn't mean you
should refuse to accept it